after over two weeks and 29 hearings it
was time to vote on the dream team
Parliament is a parliament and the vote
is a vote so I hope that we will of the
majority no I think it's going to be
good we already had the chance of
working with the Parliament for the
hearings so today were my sights willing
to listen to the Parliament and then to
start next week we look forward for this
work to address actually those issues
what European citizens care and first
and foremost its growth and jobs mrs.
Dombrovskis touching upon a feature at
the heart of the unica philosophy vivid
Gemma convicts uma coisa que septum is
no se valla Commission ladder Nations
seubert noodle system our approach a
lease it by an eye opener develop SWAT
musician at the time of the hearings
criticism was levelled at the lack of
respect given two portfolios but mr.
Younker quick to show that his is a
different Commission had this to say
Yakutia vivo coup d'etat snow too sir
kisses on plan be fed k javadi's effect
le competence amatya dominicana y de
Patri pharmaceutique Olaf is not per se
de perfil de camisa a la santé vessel me
on Jacques de marsay interior GDC day
today effective say competence hookah me
sir a la santé despite the rhetoric some
weren't buying what he was selling we
see the appointment of a french
socialist with their record on the
growth and stability pact as a mistake
it's like rather like Putin an alcoholic
in charge of a wine bar our group will
not join this cozy consensus we will
abstain medium gosh Tim via who not the
ryan swansea damaged a leaf st
commission is kabir it
so there we had it but for those who had
voted no was the result of bitter pill
to swallow our know yeah it's not a no
against Europe this deal limited the
democratic rights of the Parliament and
I think this is a shadow on the new
start of the European Commission in
democracy and majority in parliament
decides the others can say they don't
agree but if you have a strong majority
you can do strong politics and the
former commissioner also had these words
of advice each Commissioner now has to
go or to basics see what is feasible to
be done and start to put in onto paper
the projects for the future there is no
time to lose the time at least four
winners photo before all the hard work
begins